من مستشفى ناصر في خان يون سينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره وائل الدحدوح وائل انت
حرفيا تجسد معاناه الحرب والصمود في قطاع
غزه كيف تلخص لنا 100 يوم من الحرب في
غزه الحرب كلها اهوال وخطوب
ومعاناه والم جلال بالتاكيد يعني لا ي في
الحرب الا هذه المفردات مع الاسف وخلال
هذه الحرب كانت هذه الكلمات وهذه المعاني
ربما لم يسبق لها مثيل في حروب سابقه نحن
قمنا بتغطيه الحروب السابقه على قطاع غزه
وكانت صعبه وصعبه جدا ولكن مثل هذه الحرب
بكل تفاصيلها لم نشاهد ولم تمر ربما في
تاريخ قطاع غزه على الاطلاق لا من حيث حجم
الدمار الذي حل بالمناطق الفلسطينيه
بالمدن بالقرى بالبلدات ولا حتى باعداد
الشهداء الذين قتلوا وسفح دماؤهم في غارات
اسرائيليه كانت ابتداء بتدمير المنازل فوق
رؤوس ساكنيها بغض النظر عن الاعداد التي
تكون داخل هذه المنازل من اطفال ونساء
وشيوخ ومدنيين هذا لا يهم مربعات سكنيه
ازيحت عن الخارطه بالكامل ايضا بمن فيها
من السكان واحيانا هناك تدمير ممنهج
للمباني ولبنى التحتيه وللمعالي وهذا كله
بالتاكيد يعني نجم عنه معاناه مختلفه جدا
عن كل المعاناه التي شاهدها ربما سكان
قطاع غزه فيما مضى من حروب ومن حصار ومن
موجات تصعيد هذه الحرب مختلفه كما ونوعا
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي هو للمره الاولى
التي تقرر فيها اسرائيل قطع التيار
الكهربائي بالكامل وقطع المياه بالكامل
واغلاق المعابر بالكامل وكلها في نهايه
المطاف قرارات تساوي ربما جرائم ضد
الانسانيه لا يعقل ان تقطع الكهرباء
والمياه عن شعب اعزل يعيش تحت حصار منذ 17
عاما هو قطاع غزه شعب يسكن نحو مليونين
و300 الف مواطن فلسطيني يقطنون في قطاع
غزه ويتعرضون الى هذا النوع من القتل
والتشريد هناك حاله نزوح ربما تمر للمره
الاولى في قطاع غزه اكثر من ثلثي الشعب
الفلسطيني سكان القطاع مشردون نازحون في
خيام في الشوارع في المستشفيات في المدارس
في في في في العراء بدون ادنى مقومات
الحياه التي تؤمن لهم على الاقل استمراريه
الحياه وليس الحياه الكريمه بالتاكيد وائل
الى جانب كل هذا انتم الصحفيين كنتم هدفا
اساسيا في هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه ويدك اليمنى واضح الاصابه فيها اضافه
الى يعني استشهاد عدد كبير من الصحفيين
نجلك
حمزه زميلنا سامر ابو دقه وعائله زميلنا
ايضا مؤمن اشرافي ماذا تخبرنا في هذا
الواقع واقع استهداف الصحفيين بشكل مباشر
في هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
[موسيقى]
غزه الصحفيون الفلسطينيون كانوا جزء من
هذا الثمن الباهض الذي يدفعه سكان قطاع
غزه وبالتاكيد هي ايضا المره الاولى يدفع
فيها الصحفي الفلسطيني هذا الثمن الباهظ
112 من الصحفيين الفلسطينيين والمصورين
سقطوا في هجمات مباشره لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على المنازل والمؤسسات
والسيارات التي تتبع للصحفيين الفلسطينيين
دمرت مكاتب ومؤسسات ومقدرات واصيب اخرون
اسر للصحفيين الفلسطينيين استهدفت بعضها
ابيدت بالكامل مثلما هو الحال مع اسرتي
اسره الزميل ايه مؤمن شرافي اسره الزميل
ايضا ايه ابو يوسف ابو القمصان محمد ابو
القمصان مهندس البث في مكتبنا
وكثر ايضا من الصحفيين الذين تعرضت اسرهم
الى الاستهداف المباشر او غير المباشر هذا
ثمن ثمن باهظ جدا ومرعب جدا والصحفي
الفلسطيني جلال اصبح في هذه الحرب يدفع
ايه ثمنا لاضعاف مضاعفه حقيقه مر كونه
صحفي ومستهدف ويمكن ان يتحول في ايه لحظه
الى خبر او صوره او عنوان ومره اخرى كونه
كون اسرته واحبابه وجيرانه واصدقائه
يستهدفون وبالتالي هذا ثمن اخر وقلق اخر
وخوف اخر الامر الثالث هو ان الصحفي هذه
المره عاش كما يعيش كل الناس اي من كان
يعمل من خلال النزوح ومن خلال الهجره من
خلال الخيمه ومن خلال الشارع ومن خلال
فقدان المعدات نظرا للرحيل المتواصل
والمتتالية
او بعض المقتنيات والماكولات او بعض الدعم
اللوجستي وهذا امر ربما كان ثمنا باهظا
جدا و يعني يعني اضفى ربما شيء مميز
ومنقطع النظير على الصحفيين الفلسطينيين
طيب وائل كما قلت في البدايه انت ايضا
تحولت الى ايقونه للصمود الان بعد مرور
100 يوم من هذه الحرب التدمير المجازر
الاباده الجماعيه كيف تصف واقع الصمود
للغزيين مع كل ما ذكرته من نزوح ولجوء الى
خيمه وايضا في كثير من الاحيان شاهدنا
عائلات تبات بالعراء تحت الامطار كيف تصف
هذه الحاله بعد مرور 100
يوم والله حاله الصمود ما تزال مستمره
اولا لان الناس في قطاع غزه في نهايه
المطاف ليس لهم خيارات اخرى ليس لهم
توجهات اخرى ليس لديهم حلول اخرى ولا
خيارات وبالتالي امامهم فقط ان يصمدوا ان
يتعاونوا او او ان يتعاملوا مع هذا مع هذه
الحرب المجنونه وتداعياتها ولذلك تجدهم
يتاقلم مع هذا الامر صحيح انه مؤلم وموجع
ومكلف جدا على كل الاصعده ليس فقط على
يعني على على على صعيد الشهداء الذين
يسقطون لكن الذين يعيشون ليل نهار ويدفعون
اثمان باهظه من كرامتهم ومن حياتهم وحياه
اطفالهم وفي في هذا الشتاء وفي هذا البرد
وفي هذه النزوح بالتاكيد هذه اثمان باهظه
وموجعه جدا ومؤلمه جدا لكل الناس ولكن ما
هو الخيار الاخر بالنسبه للناس تجد الناس
يعبرون عن انهم صامدون باعتبار ان في
نهايه المطاف هذا عدو هذا احتلال ويقوم
باستهدافه بهذا النوع وبالتالي رده الفعل
الطبيعيه ان يصمدوا ويقفوا امام هذه
النيران وهذه الدماء التي تسفح من قبل جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شكرا لك وائل الدحدوح
مراسل الجزيره في خان
يونس